president Trump is wrapping up his
nine-day foreign trip and there's word
of progress on trade talks at the g7
summit after the second day of the
meeting President Trump will head for
home
Margaret Brennan's traveling with the
president in Sicily Margaret good
morning good morning the president's
first foreign trip ends with apparent
fractures in the u.s. alliance with the
world's great Democratic powers after
having begun the trip with a message of
unity in the Middle East the president
will leave here as the only leader
refusing to promise to abide by the
Paris climate change agreement to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
yet White House officials say his views
on that issue are evolving after having
heard direct appeals from allies like
the UK Japan and France and mr. Trump is
expected to make a decision in the
coming weeks one point of agreement is
counterterrorism all nations here
promise to improve coordination and
combat online terrorist recruitment that
security first message has been the
president's central focus since going to
Saudi Arabia last Saturday the White
House touts his outreach there to more
than 50 Muslim leaders as a major
accomplishment towards that goal but
time will tell whether all of that will
ultimately be successful today the
president will go speak to US troops in
a nearby air base before heading back to
Washington Anthony Margaret Brennan
traveling with the president insisted
thanks